despite the fact i'm a highly accredited
architect that shares some incredible
information here on youtube you guys
seem to care more about this little
tablet here than anything else
what's going on guys my name is david
tomic and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the m1 ipad
pro and some of the absolute best
applications that you can download to
maximize the capabilities of this device
i've owned this device here from the day
it was released and genuinely i do use
it every single day in conjunction with
the little keyboard and the pencil
behind me it is truly something i use
every single day for work for personal
life and for everything in between last
week i also did a long term review on
the actual ipad pro if you want to go
back and check that out i'll link that
up here so if you go back to my very
first video where i unbox this ipad pro
you'll see that my home screen has
stayed relatively unchanged most of the
apps that i downloaded from day one have
stayed on this device from day one which
means i've used them day in and day out
tried them tested them and know they are
incredible on this device now because
this is an architecture channel the
first app i'm going to talk about is
morpholio trace morpholiotrace is a
phenomenal app i've done multiple
reviews on it it's basically the best
pdf markup app you can download
on an ipad to use for architecture or
anything in between even if you're
somebody who just likes drawing and
sketching and developing their ideas
more folio is the perfect app for you
next the office apps are essential i'm
talking word and excel out of everything
potentially powerpoint depending on what
you really do but word and excel have
been critical for me i know these aren't
game changing apps but they are
genuinely must have on any device to be
able to run whatever you need in a
professional or personal setting
now i do also recommend that you jump
onto onedrive to be able to use word
excel or any of the office 365 suite
relatively seamlessly and without having
to go back and forth re-uploading and
downloading documents now on my ipad in
my productivity folder i do have adobe
lightroom and adobe photoshop to be 100
honest i've used them both once
neither are an app that is a must have
on any ipad they are good they are
phenomenal they're still better on the
computer i think lightroom is pretty
good on the ipad i have used it a couple
more times at once if i'm being fully
honest but i'm not taking photos on my
ipad so it isn't a direct transfer into
lightroom it isn't that simple most of
my photos are edited in lightroom either
on my phone or on my desktop if i'm
doing batch editing so unfortunately
neither of those two apps make the cut
what does make the cut is the discord
app i absolutely love the discord app
and if you haven't joined the discord
group chat where architects students and
anybody in the construction industry
basically comes on board talks and helps
each other out there is a discord chat
link down below it's 100 free to join
now the best thing i personally believe
about the ipad pro is the power and
capabilities to run multiple apps at the
same time the m1 chip truly does
differentiate it from anything else in
the market so that is why i do bag on
about this device so much the next app i
do recommend is a very obvious choice
for any business professional and it's
very very simple it's having two mail
apps now personally i have the original
apple mail app set up on this device for
all my personal emails then i also have
outlook set up for all my business
emails it really lets me differentiate
between home life work life and keep
that balance very very tight throughout
the year throughout the day and it is
genuinely the best thing if you are a
business professional you'll know
exactly what i'm talking about your
phone doesn't have to go off 24 7
anymore you can literally limit all of
your communication to this one device
the next app i do highly highly
recommend for any business professional
is the microsoft to-do app the microsoft
to do app has been essential on this
ipad pro it basically lets me manage my
day lets me manage my tasks and really
fundamentally plan out what my next
program is going to be so if you do need
something to manage your apps manage
your tasks and manage your life pretty
much the to-do list is phenomenal and a
must-have app now the next app that i do
use almost every single day which is
very much architecture related so feel
free to skip to the next one if this
doesn't interest you at all but it is
the archi app i have made a tutorial on
this before it basically lets you do 3d
ar models of your work in real life
using the lidar on the back of the ipad
pro because the ipad pro has that lidar
system and it has the m1 chip it runs
seamlessly flawlessly absolutely every
time it has yet to crash on me even with
some of the biggest projects i've done
today now at least in my opinion most
business professionals do manage their
own finances and they do future proof
their investments so one of the biggest
apps i actually originally bought this
ipad for believe it or not wasn't for
architecture but it was actually for
stock trading i use the comsec app in
conjunction with ig markets ig markets
on the tablet
is way way better than any desktop
version i've used of any trading
platform so if you are a business
professional looking to invest in their
own personal finances and trade on the
stock market i provide absolutely no
advice no opinion on any of that
whatsoever on this channel so if you're
looking for that this isn't the channel
for you but i do recommend the ig
markets app or any stock trading app on
the ipad because it just makes it so
simple to carry around this one paper
thin tablet with a pencil track your
stocks and actually do your fundamental
analysis when you need to on the go and
that is basically my full breakdown of
the business essential apps for an ipad
pro with the m1 chip if you're in the
architecture profession there was a
couple golden nuggets in there for you
if you're just a regular business
professional
looking to use the m1 ipad pro as your
day-to-day driver that can basically
replace your entire laptop especially
with the keyboard and pencil combination
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video i hope you found
some good apps that you haven't used
before or just got reassured that you
are using some of the best business
essential apps out there for the m1 ipad
pro if you did enjoy the video i'd
appreciate if you smash that like button
down below it helps with the youtube
algorithm feel free to leave a comment i
reply to absolutely everybody as i do
get a notification every time somebody
comments and if you enjoyed this sort of
content or are looking for more
architecture content in any way shape or
form make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below as well but like i
said that's all for me today so thank
you so much for watching and like always
i'll see you next monday